♪ ♪ ♪
Un petit comté rural du sud-est
de l'Ontario à l'avant-garde
dans la lutte contre
Il y a six ans, Oxford County
est devenu la première
municipalité ontarienne
à se fixer l'objetre d'ici 2050.
au conseil municipal du comté
lorsque la résolutla résolutla é
adoptée à l'unanimité.
"J'étais"J'étais"J'étais scepti"
confie l'élu.
Mais comme beaucoup,
les effets de plus en plustangie
climatique.
Pour atteindre sa cible de
carboneutralité, Oxford auraevra
rendre ses infrastructures
tes. C'est le cas de cette résie
pour aînés, qui comble 16 % de
ses besoins énergétiques grâce à
des panneaux solaires.
17 bâtiments municipaux sont
déjà dotés de cet équipement.
Passer as pas suffisant pour
atteindre la carboneutralité.
Oxford devra aussi adapter
son parc de véhicules.
En 2017, le comté a été
le premier au pays à se doter
de véhicule qui n'existait pas
sur le marché canadien
auparavant. Depuis,
10 ambulances sur 16 font appel
sont ravis de
leurs nouveaux véhicules etd'aue
l'exemple d'Oxford, comme
Toronto qui se dotmbulances
hybrides.
Cet expert basé à Montréal
salue ces efforts, mais souligne
seront grands et que
les résidents devront aussi
changer leurs habitudes de vie.
PIERRE-OLIVIER PINEAU, prof. HEC
- C'est techniquement possible;
de là à dire qualiste,
c'est plus difficile parce que
socialement, la population,
elle ait conscience des efforts
qui seraient néces
pour passer à une société
100 % renouvelable.
de carboneutralité d'Oxford
ne comprennent pas les émissions
des particuliers et
des entreprises,
... certains mettent quand même
la main à la pâte.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les Greenholm exploitent cette
ferme depuis des générations.
En 2013, leur ferme laitièrea at
a commencé à produire du biogaz
en utilisant du purin et
d'autres matières organiques.
Au départ, les Greenholm
cherchaient des façons de
diversifier leurs revenus.
Ils produisent maintenant
assez d'électricité pour
approvisionner l'équivalent
de 400 maisons. Mais l'opération
n'est pas simple.
♪
Pour vendre leur électricité,
les fermiers doivent eux-mêmes
se raccorder aux lignes de
courant. Un investissement depls
de dollars.
L'agriculteur se demande
quel sera le coût pour
le consommateur. Car le passage
au vert d'Oxford ne se fait pas
sans frais. Une ambulance
hybride coûte jusqu'à 30 000 $
de plus qu'un modèle diesel.
Et les panneaux solaires qui
alimentent cette résidence pour
aînés ont coûté un demi million
de dollars; deux dépenses
que le comté a faites sans
subventions de la province
ou du fédéral.
Bryan Smith habite à Oxford
depuis 30 ans. L'amateur de
plein air croit aussi que
la province et le fédéral
prennent trop de temps à agir.
S'il est conscient que son comté
ne représente qu'une goutte
d'eau dans l'océan des émissions
canadiennes, il veut rester
optimiste.
BRYAN SMITH, résident d'Oxford
- Il y a de l'espoir;
tant qu'il y a du monde
qui espère.
♪ ♪ ♪
Comme lui, plusieurs résidents
d'Oxford veulent v
être un exemple pour d'autres
municipalités canadiennes
et espèrent qu'avec l'urgence
climatique de plus en plus
reconnue, le vent
en leur faveur.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Oxf